this is the first time we have seen what
we used to call the Fab Four together at
an event since that polo match in the
summer and everyone was looking for body
language chemistry it's a very difficult
event to judge that at because the mood
of these celebrations is of course a
somber mood that said sources on the
ground say there wasn't a huge amount of
interaction between the four of them
the Royals reunited yesterday to pay
tribute to fallen soldiers at the annual
Remembrance Day service in London on the
ground William and Harry placed down a
wreath side-by-side watching from above
Megan and Kate there has been much
speculation as to why they were placed
in separate balconies et's royal expert
Katie Nicol explains that was not a
slight against Megan it wasn't a snub to
Megan when it comes to the Queen being
supported in public if it's down to two
royal women it will always be Camilla
who is going to be a future Queen and
Kate it is protocol and this is the way
things are the tone was much different
Saturday night Megan was smiling and
looked positively radiant alongside
Harry at the remembrance festival this
was the first event altogether since
Harry and Megan gave an extremely
vulnerable interview last month in
Africa I never thought that this would
be easy but I thought it would be fair
and also thank you for asking it's not
many people have asked if I'm okay the
documentary came as as a bit of a
bombshell for the royal family when
Megan thanked the interviewer that led
to some members of the household Kate
Camilla both reaching out making a point
of contacting the couple to say we are
here for you
[Music]